¿Quién controla el capitalismo mundial?
Todos habéis oído hablar de la conspiración
reptiliana, los Rothchild o George Soros…
pero hay un actor aún mucho más importante
en el que nadie repara: El Gobierno de Noruega. Sí. Noruega no sólo uno de los países más
ricos del mundo sino también uno de los más influyentes en las finanzas internacionales
¿Creéis que nos hemos vuelto locos? ¡Para
nada! Al final de este vídeo, lo entenderéis
todo.
Noruega es el único país del mundo donde
el Black metal satánico se considera un género
de música comercial. Es decir, que si tú
vas a Noruega y pones la radio, lo más probable
es que no suene Maluma sino bandas como Gorgoroth,
Mayhem o… Lilli Meister y su megahit titulado
MY ASS.
Lo cierto es que Noruega es uno de los países
más ricos del mundo: al mismo nivel que Suiza
o Irlanda ¡Pero no sólo eso! También es
uno de los países más igualitarios del planeta,
es decir, con menos diferencias entre ricos
y pobres. Tienen uno de los estados del bienestar
más generosos que existen, un nivel de vida
envidiable y, además es el país donde se
educó elRubius, amo y señor del YouTube
hispanoparlante.
Pero todo esto ya lo sabéis. Sin embargo,
la sombra de Noruega es mucho más alargada…
Hablamos de uno de los actores con más poder
en el capitalismo mundial. Tal vez usted no
lo sepa pero el Gobierno de Noruega está
en la trastienda de las principales corporaciones
de nuestro planeta…
¡No os vayáis todavía! Ya sé lo que estáis
pensando y no, este vídeo no es una colaboración
con Mundo Desconocido. Veréis, Noruega tiene
una población que a duras penas llega a los
5 millones de habitantes, es decir, que hasta
el área Metropolitana de Madrid está más
poblado. Sin embargo, estos 5 millones de
habitantes son accionistas de las principales
empresas del mundo ¡Tal cual como lo oís!
El Gobierno de Noruega tiene uno de los mayores
fondos de inversiones del mundo, con acciones
en casi todas las empresas
¿Es probable que, sin saberlo, elRubius tenga
acciones en compañías como Apple, Facebook
o Tesla? Usted no lo sabe. Yo tampoco. No
sabemos si elRubius tributa en Noruega…
así que… Pero la pregunta que sí podemos
contestar es ¿Por qué Noruega es tan rico?
¿Cómo han llegado hasta aquí? A estas alturas,
muchos estaréis pensando en una palabra:
PETRÓLEO. Efectivamente, Noruega es uno de
los mayores productores de zumo de dinosaurio
del mundo. Sin embargo, no se parecen en nada
al resto de países petroleros. Por ejemplo,
fijaos en esta foto del skyline de Riyadh,
la capital de Arabia Saudita.
Parece una ciudad de ciencia ficción ¿verdad?
Rascacielos, edificios ultramodernos y montones
de lucecitas.
Y ahora, mirad esta otra de Oslo, la capital
de Noruega.
Creo que empezáis a notar las diferencias
¿Verdad?
Si seguís VIsualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis que tener petróleo no es sinónimo
de ser rico. Es más, como podéis ver en
esta gráfica, el crudo noruego es dos veces
más caro de extraer que, por ejemplo, el
saudí.
Para que os hagáis una idea: la mayor parte
del petróleo Noruego viene de los yacimientos
que hay en el mar del norte. Y esos yacimientos
los comparte junto con otros países como
Reino Unido. Sin embargo, Noruega ha sido
el país que más rendimiento ha sacado al
petróleo del mar del Norte.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando! ¡Otro
vídeo más de VisualPolitik donde nos cuentan
como Noruega se volvió rica privatizando
empresas! ¡Pues nada de eso! Noruega es un
ejemplo de libro de lo que podríamos llamar
capitalismo de estado.
Así que ¿Por qué Noruega es tan rica? ¿Por
qué son tan influyentes? ¿Qué significa
que un gobierno invierta en bolsa? Hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes vamos
a ver un poco de historia.
LA ENFERMEDAD HOLANDESA
Tenemos que ser honestos: Noruega nunca ha
sido un país especialmente pobre… pero
tampoco especialmente rico. En los años 50,
los Noruegos tenían un nivel de vida similar
a los franceses. Esto significa: más ricos
que los españoles pero muy por debajo de
sus vecinos suecos o, por supuesto, los estadounidenses.
Por aquel entonces, nadie pensaba que Noruega
pudiera tener petróleo. Pero las cosas cambiaron
en el año 1959. En ese momento es cuando
SHELL empezó sus prospecciones en el mar
del norte. Shell es la petrolera de Países
Bajos, y estaba buscando posibles yacimientos
en las costas de su país. Y Eureka! Encontraron
unas pequeñas bolsas de gas. Si hay gas,
tiene que haber petróleo cerca. Así que
continuaron con las prospecciones. Y así
es como descubrieron uno de los mayores yacimientos
de petróleo del mundo. Un yacimiento que
está en las aguas de Reino Unido y Noruega.
Durante los años 60, Shell consiguió licencias
de explotación en estos dos países. Años
más tarde, en 1972, el Gobierno de Noruega
creó su propia empresa de petróleo: STATOIL.
Y así es como estalló el petroboom del Mar
del Norte.
Durante los años 70, el dinero entraba en
Noruega a calderadas. En sólo 3 años, duplicaron
su renta per cápita. De repente, el sueño
de todo noruego era trabajar en esa pujante
industria del zumo de dinosaurio ¿Quién
quiere pescar salmones cuando puede forrarse
trabajando en el petróleo? Suena fantástico
¿Verdad?
Bueno… pues no. A este fenómeno se le conoce
como la enfermedad holandesa o… maldición
de los recursos naturales. Básicamente, cada
vez que un país encuentra petróleo, la economía
se vuelve loca. El gobierno se puede permitir
despilfarrar el dinero y bajar los impuestos.
Y todos los ciudadanos quieren trabajar en
el sector del petróleo, que es el más rentable
¿Conclusión? En pocos años, tu economía
sólo produce un producto: petróleo. Y en
cuanto baja el precio del barril, el país
entero se va a pique. Lo hemos visto en Venezuela
y lo estamos viendo en Arabia Saudita o Bahrein.
Y aquí es donde llega la gran diferencia
de actitud entre Noruega y reino Unido. Ambos
países tenían gobiernos laboristas pero…
sus posiciones no podían ser más distintas.
En 1976, Reino Unido estaba en mitad de una
de sus peores crisis económicas. Así que
el gobierno estaba deseando exprimir al máximo
todo el potencial del Mar del Norte. Noruega,
sin embargo, tenía una situación mucho más
estable y podían permitirse esperar ¿Y eso
qué significa? Pues primero, que el Gobierno
puso unas regulaciones muy estrictas a la
industria. Por un lado, el 50% de todas las
explotaciones de petróleo, tiene que estar
en manos de STATOIL. Por el otro, las petroleras
extranjeras tienen que pagar un 78% de impuestos
sobre sus beneficios en el país ¡Pero aquí
no termina la cosa! El Gobierno Noruego puso
toda clase de límites a la producción de
petróleo. Fijaos en esta gráfica.
Aquí podéis ver cómo Reino Unido disparó
su producción desde el primer momento. A
finales de los años 70, los británicos ya
producían más de millón y medio de barriles
al día mientras que Noruega no llegaba ni
a la tercera parte. Durante los años 80,
con Margaret Thatcher, Reino Unido continúa
exprimiendo su zumo de dinosaurio como si
no existiera mañana mientras que Noruega
sigue tomándoselo con calma.
¿Qué conseguían con esto? Pues desincentivar
que todas las fuerzas productivas del país
se volcaran en el petróleo.
¡Pero esperad otro momento porque hay otra
gran diferencia entre Noruega y Reino Unido!
Veréis, en los años 80, el Gobierno de Margaret
Thatcher privatizó British Petroleum. Sin
embargo, el Gobierno Noruego siempre ha mantenido
el control sobre STATOIL. Hoy en día, STATOIL
ha cambiado de nombre, ahora se llama EQUINOR,
pero el gobierno sigue teniendo el 67% de
la propiedad de la empresa.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¡Oh! ¡Dios
mío! ¡Noruega es un país socialista! Bueno,
más bien podríamos comparar su sistema económico
con el de China. Muchos teóricos lo llaman
CAPITALISMO DE ESTADO. Es decir, que aunque
el Estado controla una buena parte de la economía,
se comporta como si fuera una empresa privada.
Y esto ¿Qué significa? Pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
EL PAÍS QUE INVIERTE EN BOLSA
Antes de empezar tengo que hacer un paréntesis.
Porque estos acordes tan bonitos y dulces
que están sonando son la música de ENDEATHED,
un grupo de Black Metal de… ¡Colombia!
Exacto, no son noruegos pero estoy seguro
de que arrasarían si tocaran en Noruega porque…
¡Mirad que bien suena! ¡A ver si aprendes,
Maluma!
Volviendo a nuestra historia ¿Recordáis
esas dos fotos que os ponía al principio
del vídeo? Otros países como Arabia Saudita
han aprovechado esos pingües beneficios del
zumo de dinosaurio para gastar cual estrella
de hip hop un viernes por la tarde. Sin embargo,
los distintos gobiernos noruegos, tanto laboristas
como conservadores han continuado midiendo
hasta el último céntimo que gastan ¿Y todo
esto qué significa? Pues que todo ese dinero
que ganaban con las ventas de crudo se guardaba
en una hucha.
Y así es como llegamos al año 1990. En ese
momento, el Parlamento Noruego se da cuenta
de que tiene un montón de dinero ahorrado,
que el precio del petróleo puede subir o
bajar dependiendo del mercado internacional
y que… lo mejor que pueden hacer es diversificar
su economía ¿Y qué mejor forma para hacerlo
que… invertir en bolsa? Pues como decimos
en VisualPolitik, dicho y hecho.
Así es como nació el FONDO DE PENSIONES
NORUEGO, también conocido como el FONDO SOBERANO
NORUEGO. Es decir, que el Banco Central Noruego
controla su propio fondo de inversiones.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos…
¿Un fondo soberano? Bueno, hay muchos otros
países que también tienen fondos soberanos.
Y tenéis razón: el Gobierno Chino también
invierte en empresas, y Australia, y Emiratos
Árabes Unidos…
Entonces ¿Qué tiene de especial este Fondo
Soberano Noruego? Pues… de entrada, el tamaño.
Para que os hagáis una idea, este fondo de
inversiones tiene más de 1 billón de dólares
estadounidenses. Y sí, he dicho billón en
castellano: en inglés sería trillón. Es
decir, que si lo repartimos entre todos los
ciudadanos noruegos, toca a casi 200.000 dólares
por persona.
¡Habéis oído bien! Eso significa que si
elRubius sigue siendo ciudadano Noruego, tiene
más de 200.000 dólares invertidos en bolsa.
¡Pero aquí no termina la cosa! Según la
ley noruega, nadie puede tocar ese dinero
para gasto público. Es decir, que el Gobierno
noruego sólo puede utilizar los beneficios
que da este fondo, pero no el capital invertido.
Y, creedme, no hablamos de poca cosa.
Cómo el fondo soberano noruego ganó 130.000
millones de dólares en un año
Hablamos de uno de los mayores fondos de inversión
de todo el mundo. Y, por ley, sólo puede
invertir en empresas extranjeras. Y por eso,
a día de hoy, tienen el 1,5% de las acciones
que existen en las bolsas de todo el mundo.
Por supuesto, como todos los fondos de inversiones,
hay años peores y años peores. Según muchos
analistas, las estrategias de este fondo son
demasiado conservadoras y, en muchos casos,
no dan todo el beneficio que deberían. Pero
lo cierto es que Noruega no sólo utiliza
este dinero para diversificar su economía.
También es un arma política…
El fondo del petróleo Noruego, con 905.000
millones de dólares, saca su músculo en
el accionariado
El fondo soberano más grande del mundo se
ha opuesto a 6.700 decisiones de empresas
el año pasado
Veréis, por un lado, el Banco Central Noruego
publica todos los años una lista negra con
todas las empresas donde no invierten por
razones éticas. Eso incluye a empresas de
armas, de tabaco o que tengan algún tipo
de caso de corrupción ¡Pero eso es sólo
el principio! Veréis, tener acciones de una
empresa no sólo es una forma de ganar o perder
dinero. También te da derecho a participar
en las juntas de accionistas. Y, cuantas más
acciones tengas, más importante es tu voto
en las decisiones de esa empresa. Por ejemplo,
desde verano de 2018, Facebook se está empezando
a tomar en serio los algoritmos que detectan
las fake news. También están empezando a
reducir la brecha salarial entre hombres y
mujeres. Pues bien, esas dos decisiones son
fruto de un consejo de accionistas que se
celebró en verano de 2018 ¿Y quién puso
estos temas encima de la mesa? ¡Exacto! ¡Noruega!
Y lo mismo ocurre con otras empresas.
Noruega apoya la postura de los activistas
en las reunions de Alphabet
Como ya sabéis, Alphabet es la empresa matriz
de Google. Pues bien, una serie de accionistas
minoritarios querían que Google refinara
el filtro de fake news. Y lo mismo pueden
decir en Apple. En este caso, Noruega es el
8º accionista mayoritario con más de 8000
millones de euros invertidos. Y tampoco se
callan en sus reuniones de activistas. En
general, Noruega está empujando a que las
grandes empresas del mundo entero cambien
sus políticas en muchísimos frentes. Por
supuesto, está la brecha de género ¡Pero
no sólo eso! Parte de lo que podríamos llamar
la “ideología noruega” incluye cosas
como esta.
El Fondo soberano noruego se centra en los
altos sueldos de los ejecutivos
¡Exacto! En muchos casos, los ejecutivos
de las grandes multinacionales cobran sueldos
millonarios, pese a que la empresa esté en
pérdidas. Lo hemos visto con muchos de los
bancos que casi se arruinan durante la crisis.
Como os podéis imaginar, a los accionistas
de esas empresas no les hace mucha gracia.
Pero es difícil alzar la voz cuando tienes
sólo unas pocas acciones. Pues bien, Noruega
actúa como el gran altavoz de todos esos
inversores barra activistas que no sólo quieren
ganar dinero, sino también cambiar el modo
en el que se dirigen las grandes compañías.
En VisualPolitik hablamos de cómo un gobierno
intenta influir en otro gobierno. Pero, en
este caso, se trata de un gobierno influyendo
en las empresas de todo el mundo. Mientras
tanto, los noruegos pueden vivir tranquilos.
Con un fondo soberano tan extremadamente diversificado,
pueden dormir tranquilos sabiendo que, aunque
el petróleo caiga, tienen su futuro asegurado.
Y ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿Creéis
que es buena idea el hecho de que un estado
se meta a invertir en bolsa? ¿Hasta qué
punto Noruega ejerce una buena o una mala
influencia en las empresas? Podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentaros.
No olvidéis de visitar nuestra página de
Patreon para apoyar activamente este proyecto.
Y por supuesto, recordad que publicamos videos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!